hey oz gum bros my name is PIP ah I got
one question and one question only will
you press the button
you can turn invisible at night but you
will turn to stone if sunlight ever
touches you I'm [ __ ] tired of these
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] James [ __ ] [ __ ]
question let's get into some real ones
let's get into some real dilemmas so I
asked you brush to write me questions
let's try it out for real
alright this one is from Jamil old Steam
games are yours but before you have them
all you should first have sex with
Justin Bieber nice sentence there I mean
Justin already looks like a girl so I
think I can get into that
just don't tell Matt yeah but have you
ever heard of a [ __ ] Steam sale oh I
will not press the button I already have
way too many [ __ ] games that I'm
never gonna [ __ ] play 400 games like
I [ __ ] need 400 games sorry Justin I
won't have sex with you the next one is
from Christian eight billion subs with
how many zeros is that hundred million
views per video but you should listen to
all Lordi songs and her music videos the
[ __ ] is wrong with lordy now she's she's
a talented amazing artist who doesn't
conform to today's society stereotypes
with singing about baby and [ __ ] [ __ ]
I will not press the button try harder
next time
Jesus next one is from passing will you
press a button if your net worth will be
doubled
but Edgar will take over your YouTube
channel with no PewDiePie voiceover what
double payout okay this is not what you
want are you not entertained well I
guess I guess not so far you have not
been able to stump me Bruce try harder
this one is from Naomi right will you
press a button if you got to meet out
meat and hang out with whoever you
find Leonardo DiCaprio but they will
never remember how to pronounce your
name do you think my name is chell big
Kajal burg might see I didn't even know
how to say my own name no one knows how
to say my name I have never met anyone
outside of Sweden who knows how to say
my name
I would not it next one is from Samantha
Nomura hate comments and everyone loves
you I thought everyone loved me but
Edgar becomes a cat that sounds [ __ ]
awful ABR's a cat I can't even handle a
girl as a dog that would be everyone
knows cats are [ __ ] vicious and Edgar
is already Satan that would be like
doubling up Satan that would literally
be the apocalypse next one is some Sammy
Felix you will you press the button if
you can fly but you have you have to
[ __ ] the whole time while you're flying
okay but what's the bad what's the
downside next one is from Yvonne will
you press the button when you marry
marzi and the guy says you may kiss the
bride
and but when you kiss her you throw up
in her mouth and everyone in the room
shits themselves so first of all what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you and second of
all I what's what's wrong with you okay
will you press the buttons Satan aka
Edgar thank you will obey you no matter
what but every time you blink a
PewDiePie fan fics will become real
working I will do anything for Edgar to
listen to me
anything I am desperate this is the
phase of a desperate man in desperate
need takes desperate measurements I will
press the button thank you
alright so this one had by far the most
thumbs up it's by Nathan and it's will I
marry Marcia but lose your YouTube
channel I guess technically I have the
YouTube channel youtube.com/ such beauty
which I haven't used for years and I
could lose that one and I don't mean to
offend you Bruce but a post before Bros
am i right alright now next question it
seems that I am uncomfortable yeah I am
disappointed in you bro so you haven't
come up with good ideas at all I am dad
I thought you were my fans I suppose
it's up to me to come up with the real
dilemmas and now I will ask you
you brush ready for some real dilemmas
nothing's stupid I just dumb at once you
can touch butts without being Sam pepper
hey but you are some pepper Oh 37% of
people press the button
that means 37% of people are Sam pepper
next one no one likes you
but wait your nipples are portals to
different worlds that doesn't make
people click the button I don't know why
well 45% of people didn't press what's
wrong with you see this is why no one
likes you you will get a small loan of a
million dollars but you're Donald Trump
click in that button 66% of people don't
want a million dollars
oh I'm sorry maybe you have integrity
your nipples are penises hey wait up but
if you grab them they will work as a jet
pack with infinite fuel come on
55% of people press the button moving on
you can become invisible whenever you
want eh but you have to inject your diet
through Uranus oh this is a tight one
that I think we found a middle gap here
I guess a lot of people want to become
invisible but I guess a lot of people
also don't want any ejected I threw the
Reynes I think that's understandable
this is my favorite and it is my last
we're finishing this with a huge dilemma
I'm not gonna answer it be honest with
yourself be honest with yourself for
this one it is my favourite all right
you can have sex with your dream girl or
boy should have specified but
your mom has to watch you all do med
dilemma alright so that was William
press the button fun addition didn't you
have more fun than all these other dumb
questions probably the answer is 50% yes
thank you so much for watching this
video leave a like if you enjoyed let me
know if you wanted to do more of these
and as always stay awesome you get a
free car but it's a Honda Civic with a
spoiler what is that